we're just above the Arctic Circle it's
9am and minus 12 degrees Celsius Marty
holmgren and his partners Dina Swenson
have been organizing dogsledding tours
in Lapland since the mid-1990s visitors
can book tours lasting up to 10 days
stina's fence on has spent the night in
a tent with two guests from Belgium
they've spent two days out here in the
wilds travelling by dogsled Marty
holmgren and stina spends on breed and
train their Huskies themselves all
together they have more than 40 dogs
we're just a small company just mean
much a very personalized and have a
personal contact with the dogs it's not
like an industry not at all and we don't
do it too for the money we do it just
surviving and have a good life no love
what we do in 2003 there I'm Sweden's
official eco-label for eco tourism
companies the whole idea with
eco-tourist is to have a low impact on
nature and culture so when I go with
dogs led to we have communication with
the reindeer herders with the Sami
people the people who have reindeer in
in the area and discuss with them where
we can go when we can go the visitors
from Belgium are impressed they also
found the Swedish eco-label system very
helpful with this kind of activity it's
it's a it's important if you have that
label then at least you're sure that
everybody's is running right and yeah it
it sure helps to pick out a company yeah
p values include treating the dogs well
caring for the environment respecting
the culture of Lapland indigenous
population and offering a high quality
travel experience the groups are small a
maximum five people Marty's local
knowledge makes travelling in this
extreme climate not only exciting but
also safer and the visitors are actively
involved even taking a turn in steering
the sled
russ mark again the Swedish ecotourism
society supports companies like yoke
McGee Donna and recommends them to
travelers the strongest entrepreneurs
are those who have the right commitment
to be sustainable but also to deliver a
high quality of experience so I think it
goes hand in hand the eco-label titled
nature's best is awarded by the eco
tourism society according to strict
criteria there are now over 400
certificates like it worldwide and more
and more companies are getting on board
we definitely think you can talk about a
trend that is that echo Tories as being
the green edge of tour is really to go
out into the distant play distant places
and really having memorable experiences
in nature and the culture within the
nature is definitely something that the
many international travelers travelers
are looking for more and more the group
has now been out with the dog sled for
four hours it will soon be dark again
the meat served at lunch is from a
nearby town Marty holmgren and stina
spends on always try to use local
produce and generally care for the
environment this area is exceptional in
Sweden or Europe it's actually many
people call it Europe's last wilderness
and among all other places there are
already things like mining industries
and stuff and here it's on it so of
course we have the forest industry but
it's very much untouched nature and
that's very rare there are strict rules
for campfires the number one priority is
not to leave any traces behind whereas
in Belgium I wasn't really noticing all
this stuff because you don't get like
confronted with every day but now in
Sweden that you see these mindsets you
also get the hang of it and try to put a
little bit in your own life
for those with a desire to learn a
holiday in the Arctic Circle can be
quite educational as well as an
unforgettable experience